[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
wie ihr lecker knusprigen und vor allem
total würzige süßkartoffel pommes
herstellen könnt mittlerweile werden sie
ja in fast jedem bürger laden angeboten
und ich bestelle auch schon gar nicht
mehr die normalen pommes weil die
süßkartoffel kommen ist einfach viel
leckerer schmecken
und wir benötigen für das rezept drei
süßkartoffeln 4 ist für speisestärke 50
bis 60 milliliter wasser und einiges an
gewürzen ich schreibe euch sie mal in
die infobox damit ich euch jetzt nicht
langweile und wir gehen schon direkt
weiter zur zubereitung als allererstes
werden die süßkartoffeln vorbereitet und
hierfür werden sie einmal rundherum
geschält
das rezept mit drei süßkartoffeln reicht
übrigens für drei bis vier portionen
sobald ihr die süßkartoffeln geschält
habt könnt ihr sie dann in pommes
streifen schneiden
ihr könnt sie dicker oder dünner machen
je nachdem ich zeige euch wie ich es am
liebsten mache
[Musik]
in etwas so groß wie ein zeigefinger
sind jetzt meine süßkartoffel pommes und
bevor wir jetzt weitermachen mit der
banane müssen wir erst mal die stärkere
auswaschen
hierfür werde ich die süßkartoffeln
zuallererst in ein sieb geben und unter
kaltem fließenden wasser abspülen
[Musik]
nachdem wir sie dann komplett abgespült
haben geben wir sie in ein großes gefäß
mit kaltem leitungswasser und lassen die
süßkartoffeln darin nochmals 60 minuten
lang stehen
[Musik]
einen farblichen unterschied merkt man
jetzt nicht auch nicht im leitungswasser
allerdings ist auf dem boden der
schüssel die ganze stärke und nachdem
wir das jetzt noch einmal unter
fließendem wasser abgespült haben müssen
wir die pommes jetzt richtig gut
trocknen hierfür könnt ihr euch
küchenpapier oder auch ein küchentuch
nehmen bereitet die süßkartoffel pommes
dort aus und trocknet sie gründlich
[Musik]
für die marinade und den leckeren
geschmack geben wir die speisestärke
zusammen mit dem wasser in eine schüssel
und verrühren das miteinander
damit die marinade später an den
süßkartoffel com es besser haften kann
darf sie nicht zu flüssig sein also eher
dickflüssig und sobald ihr dann die
gewünschte konsistenz erreicht habt
kommt noch die ganzen gewürze mit hinzu
die gewürzmischung habe ich mir selber
zusammengestellt ich habe neben salz und
pfeffer auch paprika basilikum rosmarin
und knoblauch genommen das hat für mich
super harmoniert und auch sehr gut
geschmeckt und wenn das auch noch
verrührt wurde dann ist die marinade
fertig anschließend nehme ich mir immer
eine handvoll süßkartoffel pommes gebe
sie in die marinade und dann geht es
weiter auf dem herd mit unserem
frittieröl
sobald das öl in der pfanne erhitzt
wurde und das erkennt die am besten
daran dass auf dem holzstab die kleinen
bläschen aufsteigen könnt ihr die
süßkartoffel pommes einzeln hineingeben
[Musik]
hier werden am besten nur portionsweise
die süßkartoffel mit hinein gegeben denn
ansonsten will sie zusammen kleben und
das wollen wir verhindern
[Musik]
der vorgang hat bei mir fünf minuten
gedauert ich habe hier noch mal die zeit
gestoppt da könnte es noch mal sehen
nach fünf minuten nehmen wir die
süßkartoffel pommes dann aus dem fett
und lassen sie auf einem küchenpapier
abtropfen
nachdem dann alle süßkartoffeln
portionsweise frittiert wurden können
wir sie noch ein wenig nach salzen und
dann sind sie auch schon fertig
[Musik]
die süßkartoffel pommes sind nicht nur
total wird sich im geschmack sondern
auch super knusprig und das ist mir am
wichtigsten sie müssen knusprig sein und
dürfen nicht herunter hängen das geht
gar nicht und falls sie jetzt auch nach
machen möchtet dann wünsche ich euch
schon mal ganz viel spaß bei der
zubereitung und einen guten appetit bis
zum nächsten mal auf dieses kitchen
[Musik]